ronan ça bof surviennent chez le médecin
était encore malade
maintenant je pars en vacances je
voulais faire vacciner contre le sida
il n'a pas voulu attenter sérieux là les
passings d'ailleurs marqué oui j'ai
toujours avec recommencer une vidéo
comme ça je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais on entend beaucoup moins
parler du sida ces derniers temps on
n'entend plus trop parler de raggasonic
n'ont plus l'air ça peut paraître est
une bonne nouvelle parce que ça veut
dire que la recherche a fait des progrès
que les choses s'améliorent mais du coup
le problème c'est que les gens sont un
peu moins bien renseignés alors je vous
propose de refaire un petit tour de la
question avec 5 bullshit qu'on entend
souvent sur la maladie on peut attraper
le sida en embrassant quelques a walk
est on commence fort donc on va se
mettre d'accord tout de suite non on
n'attrape pas le sida en embrassant
quelqu'un et ça pour deux bonnes raisons
d'abord parce qu'on ne peut pas être
contaminé par un simple échange de
salive
même si on a des petites plaies dans la
bouche ensuite parce qu'on n'attrape pas
vraiment le sida je m'explique ce qu'on
n'attrape c'est un virus
le virus de l'immunodéficience humaine
le vih il est transmis par le sang les
sécrétions sexuelles ou de la mère à
l'enfant pendant la grossesse ou pendant
l'allaitement
une fois qu'on a été contaminé par le
vih on est porteur du virus c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut le transmettre
on dit qu'on est séropositif parce que
la sérologie c'est à dire la prise de
sang qui recherchent le virus est
positive mais on n'a pas le sida le sida
c'est le syndrome de l'immunodéficience
acquise et c'est un ensemble de
problèmes qui apparaissent
une fois que le virus s'est attaqué au
système immunitaire mais ça apparaît
plusieurs années après donc on n'attrape
pas vraiment le sida on est infecté par
le vih qui détruit certaines cellules de
nos défenses immunitaires et au bout de
quelques années des maladies en profite
pour apparaître
c'est ça qu'on appelle le sida il faut
vraiment que j'arrête de faire ce geste
1 vraiment non mais en fait plus la
peine de se protéger
maintenant guéri du sida alors non
soyons très clairs on ne guérit pas du
sida
pas encore et tant qu'on y est y a pas
de vaccin contre le sida
ça existe pas encore attention il ya des
traitements qu'ils ont pour but de
diminuer la quantité de virus dans le
sang et de maintenir les cellules de
notre système immunitaire en nombre
suffisant et donc d'empêcher l'entrée
dans la phase sida ces traitements sont
tellement efficace que parfois le virus
devient indétectable dans le sang et
qu'on peut avoir la même espérance de
vie de tout le monde quand on est
séropositif mais on n'est pas guéri pour
autant d'abord parce qu'on est sous
traitement à vie pour ça et ensuite
parce que la présence du vih dans
l'organisme provoque une inflammation
chronique qui peut finir par déclencher
d'autres malades donc si il faut
continuer à se protéger
pas la peine de ses des pistes et quand
j'ai confiance à l'autre bon ok c'est
vrai la confiance c'est important dans
un couple mais un ace que vous faites
aussi confiance à ses ex partenaires et
il n'y a pas que le sexe comme mode de
contamination donc votre compagne votre
compagnon a très bien pu être infectés
sans même avoir conscience des risques
donc avant de se passer de préservatifs
dans un couple on checke que tout est
clean
chacun fait son test de dépistage et on
attend les résultats avant de faire la
grève du latex dans ce cas de figure
mais aussi pour tous les cas dans
lesquels vous avez envie de faire une
petite vérification il y a partout en
france des cegid des centres gratuit
d'information de dépistage et de
diagnostic
il suffit de vous y rendre pour un
dépistage par simple prise de sang pour
le vih mais aussi pour les hépatites et
les infections sexuellement
transmissibles
un conte et voilà comme ça même si le
risque zéro n'existe pas vous partez sur
de bonnes bases
n'hésitez pas à faire un petit dépistage
de temps en temps je vous mets les biens
des centres dans la description
il n'y a pas de risque pour les rapports
sexuels sans éjaculation
c'est faux d'abord parce que avant
l'éjaculation il ya un écoulement d'eau
liquide près séminal dans lequel on peut
retrouver le virus dont qui peut vous
infecter
même si votre partenaire se retire avant
le bouquet final ensuite parce que les
organes génitaux sont recouverts de
muqueuses c'est à dire une peau très
fine avec des petits vaisseaux sanguins
très proche de la surface et qu'avec le
frottement
il ya un risque de contamination donc
pour être très clair en cas de
pénétration anale ou vaginale
préservatif en cas d' échange de sextoys
préservatif
ça c'est la base bon maintenant pour les
rapports oraux génitaux oro génitaux
c'est pas une marque de gâteau ça veut
dire fellation cunnilingus noter que le
risque est négligeable pour celui ou
celle sur qui on pratique l'acte mais
qui peut y en avoir un pour celui ou
celle qui est au boulot donc pour la
fellation
le risque existe notamment si le ciron
d'amour et déversé dans la bouche le
seul moyen de prendre zéro risque c'est
le préservatif
le mieux c'est de les choisir sans
lubrifiant voir aromatise en plus ça
protège aussi d infections sexuellement
transmissibles pour le cunnilingus
le risque est faible mais il ne peut pas
être complètement écartée surtout si les
muqueuses génitales ou celle de la
bouche sont abîmés et puis ya toujours
les tester si vous voulez réduire le
risque à zéro vous pouvez utiliser des
digues un peu comme chez le dentiste
personnel c'est un rectangle de latex
que vous tenez entre votre bouche et la
zone un préservatif pour la langue quoi
mes plats l'annulant gus maintenant
c'est une pratique à faible risque pour
le vih mais pour l'hépatite à donc même
consigne si vous voulez éviter tout
risque
la nique à noter que la vie de la fille
pour le reste et notamment pour les
risques liés aux injections ne partagez
pas vos seringue
ne partagez pas non plus vos paille
ainsi vous mettez des pailles dans le
met notamment à cause des risques liés
aux muqueuses irrité de manière générale
ne partageait pas d'objet en contact
avec du sang ou des sécrétions sexuelles
si la carotte craque c'est foutu alors
évidemment c'est mieux si ça n'arrive
pas mais en cas de craquage il y a le
tpe pas ce que vous donnez propolis et
là on parle de traitement post
exposition
donc si la capote à craquer ou que vous
craignez d'avoir été exposés au vih de
quelques manières que ce soit vous
pouvez aller aux urgences et demandé à
être rapidement par le médecin référent
vous pouvez aussi aller dans un service
spécialisé dans ce genre de suivi en cas
de doute ou pour connaître l'adresse du
centre le plus proche
n'hésitez pas à appeler sida info
service au 0 800 840 800 on vous
répondra 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur
24 sur place la personne qui vous
recevra évaluera les risques et mettra
en place un traitement si votre plus le
traitement est pris tôt plus il est
efficace diminue le risque d'être
contaminé mais attention il ne supprime
pas complète et donc il vous faudra
peut-être ensuite un suivi et un
dépistage pour être sûr mais ça c'est le
médecin qui vous dira voilà donc surtout
n'oubliez pas on entend moins parler du
sida mais il est toujours là et il ya 18
millions de personnes séropositives dans
le monde qui n'ont toujours pas accès au
traitement donc la recherche les projets
d'aidé aux malades et les associations
ont toujours besoin de soutien si vous
voulez apporter votre pierre à l'édifice
vous pouvez donner 5 euros au sidaction
juste en envoyant don par sms au 92 110
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos en attendant prenez soin de vous
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout pensez vous